so what are you hoping to achieve from
opening in birmingham
well this is really about talent for us
we want to diversify our footprint away
from london
in the uk we looked up and down the
country
and talent was really the main focus
where can you find a deep
diverse talent pool and birmingham has
it you know the universities here are
great
there are many engineering companies
here there are other financial
institutions here
so we're confident that we can really
build a strong workforce i gather you're
looking to hire a hundred people by the
end of the year you're already at batter
gather
so we seeded it with about 30 existing
government employees you know just to
make sure that yeah we got off on the
right foot from a cultural point of view
you're making sure that the business and
the operation stayed connected and we've
you know hired you know close on 70
externally
um so we're at around 100 now and we'll
look to continue to grow it you know we
in the short term we probably get to a
couple of hundred and then we'll see
where it goes from there there's no cap
on how big this could become it really
depends on
how it evolves you know what skills
we built here and it won't just be a uk
operation necessarily you know the real
potential will be if this can become
a center of excellence
for certain global functions uh you know
and then obviously the scale can be
quite significant and what sort of
activities will be taking place here are
you transplanting existing activities
from london or is this a whole building
something from the ground up a little
bit of both um
many many different parts of the firm
will be represented here engineering
talent
you know is
one of the most important streams that
we're going to tap into here so we're
going to have a lot of our engineers you
know sitting up here but
you know across
our firmwide strategy group we've got
people here human resources we've got
people here some of our loan origination
servicing people
i'm so many different parts of the firm
will be represented
so what sort of skills that you're
looking for people
use engineering is a big part of it
obviously you know we work in an
industry where you know kwan skills are
at a premium
building platforms building your trading
platform systems you know really really
important you know and so so the
engineering talent that exists and if
you look at the some of the traditional
companies in this part of the country
they obviously have a strong engineering
base which is one of the things that
encouraged us to come here so will there
be client-facing activities carried out
here as well
not at the beginning um
but let's see let's see how it evolves
we obviously cover many of the
big organizations that are based here
but we've covered them you know out of
london and i i think for the
you know into the intermediate future
that's where that base will will stay
but let's see what opportunities present
themselves and has goldman tried this
anywhere else in the world or is this a
first
no no we've done it look we've
yeah so if i go back in in in history we
set up in london about 50 years ago
so it took us 50 years to to get our
next step in the uk to birmingham but
through that time we built out a
platform and a group of officers a
network of officers you know right
across europe
you know a number of years ago we set up
in stockholm there was a great pool of
engineering talent up there and we have
an important number of people there
really focused on engineering you're
sitting alongside our client-facing
people
out of india out of bengaluru we've got
we've got an office of six and a half
seven thousand people in bengaluru
about two thousand of those really
service our london operations warsaw we
go close on a thousand people so we've
built you know operations you're really
all around the world you're servicing
global operations and a lot of it's
servicing our london operation and this
is another example
so obviously uh it's been a traumatic 18
months for
the global economy for the uk economy
how has goldman's in the uk navigated
its way through the the last 18 months
you sort of wish it was over don't you
but it's uh
it's it's not and
so far i think we've navigated well
we obviously went through that period
where over a week or two we moved
everybody from the office here to
working from home
and i can only applaud
our people but frankly people across our
industry and many other industries in
terms of how they continue to deliver on
their operations and their businesses
and continue to service the economy and
we achieved that
and i think we did it exceptionally well
the the business flows over the last 18
months have been at extraordinary levels
and we've serviced that you know largely
you know remotely obviously we on a path
to coming back to the office we're
getting you know great response from our
people they are coming back
and i think they're enjoying that
connectivity and interacting with each
other and you you're certainly post
summer here in the uk it feels like
we've taken another step forward good
attendance good engagement and frankly
great feedback from our people
i mean m a volumes have been astonishing
at the outset of the pandemic would you
have envisaged that
not at these levels no i
and of course they've sustained
themselves they
you go back to the early stages of the
pandemic you know that was much more
about liquidity you know financing
very quickly though corporates you know
started to focus on the strategic
challenges that would lie ahead the need
for scale the need to invest in
technology the need to adjust the global
supply chains you know and that meant
portfolio adjustments and and moved you
know onto the m a footing but look you
know this year on the m a front looks to
exceed 2007 which was the last record
yeah we're right at those levels already
and we still got another three four
months to go so exceptional activity
activity has peaked in terms of gdp
growth do you feel do you get a sense
that we're sort of slightly coming off
the boil
well we are growing from much reduced
levels and i think this is an important
point of course so the question the
first question is so when do we get back
to pre-covert levels and depending on
which economy you're in you're
there or thereabouts now
but of course we've given up two years
of growth
um so there's you know there's still a
lot more catch-up
this next period will be slower than the
period we've just had
but i think still you know very healthy
and positive levels um and i think
driving good activity